[Music]
scarlet nexus is an
original creation from some of the
creative minds behind the much-loved
tales of hesperia it's a stylish
collision of
anime and western sci-fi ideas and
designs
that has birthed an innovative new
sub-genre
brain punk
brain punk can be thought of as the
natural and ultimate outcome of what we
currently dub the internet of things
which is to say that we no longer
require anything so primitive as
physical devices
because everyone's brains are now
connected to the vast
cy net network coinciding with this
major technological development
people started to develop extra sensory
powers
and the world was forever changed
perhaps not so coincidentally
it also marked the appearance of the
others
grotesque hybrids of organic and
man-made objects
with an insatiable hunger for human
brains
this in the game's vaguely defined
timeline
occurred well over half a millennium ago
and for the last 560 years
the other suppression force or osf has
been recruiting psionically gifted
individuals
to suppress the grey mata munching
monstrosities
the others fall from the sky regularly
emerging from a mysterious phenomenon
known as the extinction belt much like
the weather
humanity has figured out how to forecast
these figurative downpours
minimizing civilian casualties while the
osf patrol red zones
on others clean up duty in scarlet nexus
you have the choice of playing as two
recent osf recruits
helping to defend the country of new
himacha
yuito's sumaragi is an optimistic and
energetic boy
whose family has close ties to both the
government and the osf
as a sword specialist he favors close
quarters attacks
which he can combine with powerful
psychokinetic abilities
[Music]
at the other end of the personality
spectrum is kasani randall
a young girl scouted by the osf due to
her best-in-class abilities
in contrast to yuito's optimism kasane
is considered
cold and unapproachable although is
known to be kind
to those who've broken through her tough
exterior
much like her approach to her colleagues
kasane prefers to keep her enemies at a
distance
using ranged multi-blade attacks
alongside her psychokinetic powers
your choice of hero means that you'll
only witness the game's story from their
perspective
and while yuito and kasana's narratives
interweave at key moments throughout
it's only by playing through the game as
both characters
that you'll understand the full picture
but it's not just the pair stories and
play styles that differ
the osf members you party up with change
according to your chosen protagonist too
yuito's first ally is his childhood
friend hanabi ichijo
whose fiery impulsive nature is
reflected in her
aptitude for pyrokinesis in kosane's
branch you'll initially partner up with
shiden
ritter an electrokinesis specialist
thanks to scinet
yuito and cassani can temporarily
receive their allies abilities via sas
also known as the struggle arms system
this brain-to-brain transferal is
visualized by red cables
which if you haven't connected the dots
yet are the eponymous scarlet nexus
in a curious piece of scarlet nexus law
younger brains produce stronger psionic
powers
which has led to many members of the osf
taking anti-aging drugs
to keep their abilities at their peak
this means that the appearance of
certain osf companions
are quite deceptive as you progress
through the story
you'll meet and team up with other
psionic specialists that will gift you
with among
other sas powers hyper speed
invisibility
duplication clairvoyance and
teleportation
you'll have opportunities to chat and
exchange psychic emails to build bonds
with each party member
which will enhance the sas abilities
available to you in combat
you can make your own special connection
to scarlet nexus's unique brain
punk world when it releases on june 25th
[Music]
play it on the all-new xbox